what we're going to do in this video is
a little bit more of a deep dive into
the House of Representatives now we've
already talked about how either chamber
of Congress can introduce general
legislation and if it gets approved by
one chamber it has to be voted on and
approved by the other chamber but the
House of Representatives has some
specific constitutional powers so for
example impeachment proceedings would
start in the House of Representatives in
other videos we have talked about
impeachment is not the removal from
office of say the president it is just a
formal indictment
now if the House of Representatives is
able to impeach someone say the
president then it would go to the Senate
to try the impeachment to decide whether
to actually convict the person now we've
also talked about the house being the
place where tax and revenue bills would
initiate so if we're talking about tax
or revenue these bills would start in
the House of Representatives the other
areas where the Senate has more
influence by the Constitution are in
ratifying treaties and this is really
one of the significant levers where the
Senate has more influence on foreign
policy and also confirmation of
presidential appointments either into
the executive branch if we're talking
about the cabinet or judicial
appointments the federal court system
including the US Supreme Court but
beyond these constitutional powers
there's differences in how these
different houses are run and what we'll
see is these processes result in the
Senate being more deliberative in the
video on filibuster we talked about how
hard it is to end a debate in the Senate
while in the house the power is more
centralized amongst not just the
majority party but amongst the
leadership in that majority party we're
talking about folks like the Speaker of
the House and the inner circle of the
Speaker of the House and we'll see why
this is in a second and to appreciate
this centralized power and you could
argue a more efficient versus
deliberative process in the House of
Representatives you just have to
remember that if we have a bill coming
to the house it will first go to the
speaker who decides which committee it
goes to so let's say it goes to some
type of a
committee right over here now just as in
the Senate this committee can conduct
hearings they can have some debate and
the leadership of the committee can
decide to bring it to the House floor
but in reality what happens is is that
the Rules Committee gets involved and as
we've talked about in previous videos
the Rules Committee in the house has a
significant amount of power they can
decide assuming a bill gets through
committee they can decide to what degree
it is debated on the House floor they
can even decide on the rules of debating
they could decide on the House floor is
it going to be debated as the house or
is it going to be debated as the
committee of the whole which happens in
the House chamber but in this situation
the house discusses it as a very very
very large committee and it's usually
done for very important legislation or
even sometimes complex legislation where
they want to pass it in a more efficient
way and so the existence of a very
powerful Rules Committee you have a
Rules Committee in the Senate but they
really don't have much power but in the
House of Representatives some would
argue that they are the most important
or most powerful Committee because they
decide how and when things get debated
they even decide if there is a debate or
where their amendments can even be added
to bills remember in our discussion of
the Senate once something even goes to
the Senate floor it's still open to
filibuster and you still need those 60
votes for cloture on a bill that is not
the case in the House of Representatives
now in theory there are some mechanisms
where someone could bypass some of this
so for example in a committee in the
House of Representatives just as in the
Senate the leadership of a committee
could decide to not bring something to
vote they could just put a bill into
limbo not debate it but if someone
really wants it to come to the House
floor they could use something called a
discharge petition this charge petition
but in order to get a discharge position
in order to make it successful so that
that bill actually goes through the
House floor even if the committee
the Chairman doesn't want it to go there
it has to get a majority vote of
Representatives and so you could imagine
if it's someone from a minority party
trying to have a discharge petition
petition it would be very difficult
because how are they going to get 51% of
the 435 representatives to vote for it
and so that's why in practice this is
actually not that typical so the big
picture here beyond the constitutional
powers that are given to the house or
the Senate in general the House of
Representatives is much more
hierarchical the power is centralized
especially within the majority party and
because of that centralized power it
allows the house to get bills moving
much faster especially once they go
through the House floor you don't have
this notion of a filibuster and this
notion that you have to get a
supermajority in order to actually get a
vote and get something passed